all that normal girl stuff and mom stuff
it's part of the bonding you know that
having kids the same age angelina jolie
and salma hayek dish on their eternal
bond following their joint debut in the
marvel universe e.t caught up with the
stars at the uk premiere of eternals
which hits theaters november 5th
angelina a red carpet fashionista for
decades says it's been therapeutic to
watch her kids have a fashion moment of
their own on the press tour i think the
important thing is they they've been
they haven't made a choice they've been
public sin for their whole lives and so
to try to find a way where they can not
be kind of overwhelmed by it but just be
in it in a comfortable way and it's a
tiny piece of our life you know
everybody we have
we are we are just a family but this
little piece of our life where this is a
moment i'm happy that they're able to uh
to have some fun with it and not take it
too seriously and
and start to explore themselves even
with their fashion and yeah how long do
we have
seven days another perk of joining the
mcu salma and angelina bringing their
two families together yeah valentina and
the girls yeah yeah
all that normal girl stuff and mom stuff
now here's a cute moment selma's
daughter valentina on the red carpet
looking for angelina's kids
that's also her day tonight right so
this is our dates for the night i saw
her and i was like where's shy and z
later but they become good friends it's
part of the bonding you know that having
kids the same age just hanging out with
the gang you know and it's extra special
when you have a project together that
you're all passionate about eternals
follows a diverse team of superheroes
who come together like a family as they
save the world angelina says the group's
dynamic hits close to home it's not as
much my life but it is my
yes when i take my kids to it when i was
standing with the cast i was
i would just feel i look around at this
family in in the film and of course i i
think oh z could be makari for halloween
mad could be gilgamesh and that's not
for many
families represented have i been able to
to feel that because we are a mixed
family so it's a it's wonderful okay but
would the oscar winner be interested in
living forever like these heroes i
wouldn't want it i think
i think it's very important for us to
to appreciate life and and to know that
it is because it's fleeting i think we
we live more fully and we
we have a different experience with it
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them angelina's kids were also by
her side at the premiere in los angeles
last week where she admitted to e.t they
weren't exactly thrilled about her
spandex duds in the new movie i heard
your kids were shook by your costume oh
well i mean would you want to see your
mother wearing that
[Laughter]
listen if you got it you got it
they were like
i don't know i think they're still they
haven't seen the movie so i mean your
mom walks in in a full spandex gold
outfit with gold hair and you just think
what do you do for a living what are you
how do you get back in your robe
[Music]
you